[Music]
this morning on the dish cole featuring
chef santiago lastra gq uk's chef of the
year for 2021.
luster creates mexican food without
traditional mexican ingredients
eating at england's only michelin star
mexican restaurant is an experience like
no other as we found out on a recent
trip across the pond
when you first found out that you were
becoming the first mexican restaurant
ever in england to have
a michelin star
what was your reaction well i was really
proud i was really proud santiago
lastra's origin story doesn't begin the
way it does for many internationally
famous michelin chefs i didn't really
have this beautiful story of like my
grandmother was rolling past a while
while i was underneath the table kind of
thing you were eating fast food yeah i
was eating yeah i was eating fast food
at the age of 15 lastra bought a box of
ritz crackers at the supermarket
and made a crab dip recipe that was
featured on the box
he has never looked back
lobster began traveling the world to
learn and cook including time at
high-end restaurants in spain
russia and denmark
until he got an idea on the beach in
mexico an hour and a half south of
cancun
coal means cabbage yeah why why name it
that so coral it means cabbage with a c
and what we want is to
represent that things that are under
value can be special if you put them in
the right context
like mexican food and mexican culture
and british ingredients at coal all
fresh ingredients must come from the
united kingdom not mexico meaning for
example no limes avocados or mangos
dinner is either a six or nine course
tasting and most cooking is done in the
middle of the restaurant so chefs can
see every diner and vice versa there's a
transparency on both sides that they see
who they're cooking for and you see them
cooking exactly you also can see there's
no microwave you know
we try to make dishes that are not
100 spontaneous it needs to have a story
it needs to have specific ingredients it
needs to have a specific flavor a
specific look as well like i want the
people to know that it's from color our
presentation began with nyquitole a
custard made with corn masa
traditionally from the south of mexico
lastra has given it a british spin
using apple juice and lavage with a
little bit of chili
almond milk and caviar from cornwall
your dishes have this the heat the spice
to it yes yeah so we work quite a lot on
spice we don't use for example pepper
to dress
things with salt and pepper we only use
salt and then the pepper or like the
dressing
are the chilies so the chilis will give
you heat but also will give you
seasoning lastra showed us his take on
ceviche called aguachile
made with squid
and rhubarb so in the bottom is this
paste that is made with pumpkin seeds
and
it's a type of seaweed called kelp
so then the idea of the aguachile is
that you have this liquid and then when
everything gets mixed together
it becomes like a cold soup it's
incredible i've never had anything
even remotely close to
something like this
me either
no like seriously yeah that's the idea
yeah yeah yeah the signature dish at
coal is langoustine tacos
roasted with garlic and smoked chilies
and served on a sourdough tortilla with
sauerkraut and sea buckthorn and the
head is being compressed with the juice
of the berry so yes you can squeeze it
as a lime i squeeze the head yeah so
that's it will be a piece of lime you
know and also it has all the flavor of
the
mangosteen you know i'm sold on this
version of
yeah then you just
go for it
that's amazing so this is uh inspired in
this
lobster tacos that you can have in
ensenada in baja california
the smoky char that you taste
where does that come from that is from
the heads because we grill them in the
in the chimney our next plate was a
one-of-a-kind tostada instead of meat
lostra uses beets from oxfordshire salt
baked and dressed with fermented
gooseberries and walnut oil
and underneath an emulsion made with our
bowl chili and then the beetroot is not
spicy but then the emulsion is really
spicy so but not too spicy yeah yeah
exactly so then that allows you to like
keep eating more which was a good thing
because we weren't quite done yet
there was still dessert
first up a pallet cleanser of sorts
sorrel and jalapeno sorbet with mezcal
and a pinch of salt
inspired by lasra's childhood in mexico
where all treats come
with a kick i remember when i just moved
to europe
it was so unusual for me to see candies
without chili he's like
what are you guys doing here like
how you guys get joy of your life when
you're kids like
in mexico without chili's without spicy
sweating like without sweat
in mexico you're a child you're like
with your friends just like everyone is
just sweating
[Laughter]
dessert number two a flan with british
mascarpone and rye
and finally benues
fried dough covered in ancho chili sugar
served with tunworth ice cream with
walnut oil and a gel made once again of
c buckthorn the idea of the dessert was
to think about a cheeseboard a british
cheeseboard and then the idea is that
you can break this like this
take one piece and then you take a
little bit of that a little bit of the
ice cream and spread it in the bunuelo
your version of a cheese yes exactly so
that would be the cracker and this will
be the cheese and sometimes you have
like jam with the cheese you know
and uh and if you close your eyes it
should remind you to eating
like a cheeseboard you know it does
right oh my gosh
it totally does right
yeah excuse me yeah
cheers man
cheers
you look so surprised like he wouldn't
deliver what he i love him he certainly
does deliver i mean inventiveness the
way he's able to melt these cheers by
the way
how the house uh the house margarita
from coal santiago
unbelievable stuff he's doing so
congratulations he tried the book he's
booked till july
just hit me up we'll figure it out jeff
you're